je veux tendent maintenant vers maylis
qui est étudiante à sciences po
montpellier et ses deux sciences po
montpellier parti le mouvement étudiant
sans tome le mot diez étudiants fantômes
alors comme beaucoup d'étudiants
vous vivez très très mal le confinement
vous avez quitté le studio vous habitiez
parce que vous aviez des crises d
angoisse à quoi ressemblait votre
quotidien d'étudiante en dans le
confinement
alors le quotidien en tout cas le mien
pendant le continent le premier
continent je pense que au départ on l'a
tous pris un petit peu comme comme
quelque chose qui allait être agréable
en fait un temps de repos parce qu'on
nous annonce et quinze jours en quinze
jours finalement c'est des petites
vacances
donc jusque là c'était c'était assez
gérable et puis les 15 jours s'est
transformée en un mois qui se
transformer en un mois et demi qui sont
transformés en deux mois qu'ils nous ont
fait passer du coup pour la première
fois nos partiel à distance inquiété
dans un cadre du coup de continuer en
général ou en fait tout le monde
vraiment tout le monde était dans la
même situation c'est un petit peu comme
si le monde s'était arrêtée de tourner
et donc jusque là je pense que pour moi
c'était assez gérable même si plus le
temps passe et moins envoyer la
perspective de l'après qu'ovide le monde
d'après covit comme on l'annoncé en fait
à partir de mai quand on serait des
consignes et on a tous un peu plus
relâchée l'été ce qui je pense a fait du
bien énormément d'étudiants et
l'annoncent de pouvoir reprendre les
cours à la rentrée dans un système
hybride en 50 % large de 50 %
d'étudiants
c'était une mesure qui en tout cas au
sein de l'ufr droit sciences politiques
montpellier a été vraiment respecté et
très bien intégré par les étudiants
puisque ça permettait de laisser le
choix à ceux qui voulaient venir de
pouvoir venir et à ceux qui préféraient
être à distance être chez eux de l'être
mais le problème c'est que cette
opportunité elle nous
a été coupée rapidement au bout de trois
semaines de cours pour nous ou 4 je sais
pas exactement mais vu qu'on était de
toute façon une semaine sur deux ça
revient pas beaucoup de temps au final
sur place mais c'était un temps qu'il y
avait vraiment été apprécié par les
étudiants ont respecté vraiment et c'est
pour ça que c'est que c'est dommage
qu'aujourd'hui on nous présente fameux
une population parce que les étudiants
sont maintenant catégorisé comme une
population qui est responsable en partie
en nous mais c'est un peu cette
culpabilité sur le dos vous allez
pourquoi on vous considère comme une
population c'est que là aussi on n'a pas
vu venir la crise avait exactement on a
pensé à des catégories qui allait
beaucoup de souffrir de confinement on
n'a pas pensé aux étudiants le malaise
est très profond on est pas la seule
étudiante affectés mais ça s'est vu oui
mais quand est ce que vous avez utilisé
l'adjectif gérable quand est-ce que
c'est devenu ingérable pour vous quand
est ce que vous avez trouvé ça
insupportable pour moi c'est vraiment
devenu ingérable et insupportable
al'annonce d'une deuxième confinement le
jour où le gouvernement a annoncé qu'on
était continue et en plus on avait un
délai beaucoup plus court
il me semble que le premier pour pour
s'adapter c'est là où je me suis dit non
c'est pas possible on va pas retomber
là-dedans parce que cette fois on savait
en fait que ça allait durer longtemps
lille était moins radical pourtant le
deuxième oui pour les étudiants non
qu'est-ce que du coup il y revient sur
multiples tout s'enchaîne nous on avait
tous les cours à distance
mais du fait du fait qu'on ait des cours
à distance
on avait plus que ça en fait à faire de
la journée donc pour pour briser la
population le deuxième continent wii a
été vécu comme plus laxistes pas pour
les restaurateurs
oui bien sûr bien sûr non mais je veux
dire pour une partie quand même le
diable un peu plus large de la
population puisque enfin dans la
revendication actuelle des étudiantes on
remet absolument pas en cause ce qui a
énormément de dépendance au confinement
vous restiez entièrement chez vous il y
avait plus je suis absolument rester
chez moi c'est le dojo on entend les
épidémiologistes toute la journée mais
pas les neuroscientifiques alors on
savait partie quand même de la médecine
le cerveau est ça qui est quand même
fascinant dans cette histoire le cerveau
est le grand oublié des dégâts
collatéraux du coc vide or le coït
s'attaque aussi au cerveau sous la forme
de la dépression du désespoir et du pire
et dota
et je regardais des chiffres quand on
regarde et la crise de 29 qui est une
crise économique très marquante c'est en
1930-31 connu des taux de suicides qui
ont explosé comme tenu la crise de 2008
donc européennes en france c'est en 2009
et 2010 que les taux de suicide ont
explosé ça veut dire que on ne se sert
pas de l'analyse que l'on peut faire d
après crise pour gérer la crise beaucoup
de gens ont même failli revenir que si
on n'a pas le taux de suicides qui
explose parce que c'est ce que disaient
les cris les chiffres aujourd'hui ça ne
veut pas dire qu'en 2022 2023
on n'aura pas un contrecoup une
explosion mais ça il faut peut-être
qu'on peut anticiper sur les faillites
si on m'assure aujourd'hui bien sûr mais
ce que je voulais dire aussi c'est que
pour les étudiants la jeunesse et 15
actuellement parle l'habitude de
l'immédiateté les médias t par tout les
moyens modernes de communication et tout
d'un coup
c est un art et un temps d'arrêt donc
ils sont complètement déboussolés par ce
changement de programme qui s'imposent
du jour au lendemain et pour une durée
indéterminée
donc non seulement il faut attendre mais
on ne sait même pas pour combien de
temps par rapport à l'immédiate et dans
lequel il était fort mais jusqu'à
présent ça et en plus donc pour être la
meilleure antidote de la dépression
c'est de pouvoir se projeter là on peut
pas se projeter
parce que c'est pour pour se projeter il
faut trois éléments qui justement manque
c'est le lien avec les autres se sentir
alors qu'ils ça manque
puisqu'on est isolé deuxièmement se
sentir en sécurité parce et l'insécurité
et troisièmement se sentir valorisé or
on a tendance un peu à se déprécier
parce qu'on n'a aucun contact avec les
autres et on ne produit rien donc ce
changement de programme auto
l'immédiateté et l'arrêt est une source
de ces comme si brusquement vous demande
de parler une autre langue anglaise ou
normales ellis a qui essaient mais
comment vous vous avez réagi à cette
situation vous allez chercher de l'aide
auprès des médecins auprès des
psychologues
non moi je me suis tourné vers l'équipe
administrative dont
dans mon lit fr j'ai vraiment la chance
d'être dans un petit ufr d'une commandé
une université à taille humaine et je
pense que c'est pas la chance que tous
les étudiants peuvent avoir aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment ce qui s'est ressenti
dans les centaines de milliers de
témoignages qu'on a pu recevoir qu'ils
étaient tous à la fois similaire mais à
la fois avec la même le même terme qui
revenait c'est mais moi je suis pas fier
c'est pas moi le pire
je suis pas pire que les autres et du
coup on a en fait on prend plus en
compte la souffrance et l'a donc
l'anxiété le stress
l'inconnu vers lequel on nous mène et
c'est ça que ça veut dire qu'on a
recours à des médicaments dans ce cas là
vous êtes ma part c'est ce qui s'est
passé c'est à dire que j'ai commencé à
avoir un suivi psychologique au sein de
mon université et parallèlement à ça je
suis allé voir un médecin pour lui faire
part aussi de ma situation et j'y suis
allé en étant dans un état anxieux déjà
de base donc il a pu me voir on va dire
sous un mauvais jour entre guillemets et
donc c'est là qu'il m'a prescrit les
anxiolytiques et des antidépresseurs
ça c'est des gens qui vont mettre des
années à décrocher des antidépresseurs
antidépresseurs que je n'ai pas commencé
le shoot pas parce que je n'ai pas bien
joué j'ai lu toute la notice est réputé
en isère donc vous n'avez pas besoin que
je voulais vous dire que 31 % des
étudiants montre des signes de détresse
psychologique contrairement à 20%
pendant le reste de l'année
universitaire de questions qu'est ce que
vous attendez demain de jean castex il
va recevoir le milieu universitaire et
deuxième question est ce que vous allez
vous mobiliser le 20 janvier pour la
réouverture des universités
je ne juge pas quelque chose de jean
castex est un oxymore ono j'ouvre juste
une parenthèse pour dire que la ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur frédéric
vidal a promis qu aurait plus de
présentiel donc le court direct et
tuerait des tuteurs qui s'occuperait en
effet des gens en difficulté mais au
moins ils puissent se tourner vers
quelqu'un dont 42 aux 25 des gueux
question avec une présence par petit
groupe d'universitaires l'éducation
christine alors pour demain en même
temps alors demain le premier ministre
va recevoir le monde universitaire
qu'est ce que vous attendez
et le 20 janvier ce que vous allez
manifester au moins pour l'ouverture des
universités
alors bien sûr que j'aimerais
manifestaient si une manifestation
s'organise sur montpellier j'aimerais
prend pas ce sera à la veille de
du début de mes examens mais partiel
pour ce semestre un semestre qui est
décisif pour les 3e année puisque c'est
le semestre qui est le plus pris en
compte pour un master et du premier
ministre
j'attendrai si possible qu'ils prennent
plus en compte la volonté de nos doyens
d'université qui nous connaît ceux qui
connaissent mieux leurs étudiants qui
ont des moyens en fait de discuter avec
eux et que des solutions soient prises
solon mais selon les promotions selon
les selon les filières finalement au cas
par cas puisque toutes les filières en
fait ne sont pas les mêmes
on a des filières je l'entends où il ya
8000 étudiants
donc bien sûr que c'est pas la même
chose que une filière où comme dans la
mienne on aime maximum 130 bien entendu
donc c'est pas du tout la même chose et
ça il faudrait que qu'on leur laisse
cette liberté puisque eux sont sont
courants en fait deux erreurs bonne des
docteurs bondi archibondé gens déclinent
toutes tailles arrive je veux tout le
monde s'exprime il en euros lancée par
le docteur karim 1 mètres d'intervalle
avec un masque alors connaît la
population la plus vulnérable
karim ne relançaient pas le docteur
j'aimerais que tout le monde s'exprime
ceux qui sont pas beaucoup exprimé dans
croque aiea et malek moi j'ai une
question qui porte plutôt sur vos études
j'ai lu que depuis le printemps 2020 un
étudiant sur six avaient renoncé à ses
études il ya d'autres problèmes qui sont
aussi relatifs aux étudiants la question
de la précarité économique parce que
beaucoup d'étudiants aux prêts aux perdu
leur job alimentaire du fait de la
fermeture des commerces de nombreux
étudiants vivent dans des lieux
extrêmement exigeants qui emplit
amplifie son sentiment d'isolement donc
je voudrais savoir si vous êtes parvenu
à suivre votre cursus normal non et si
vous avez été affecté sur le plan de
traitement économique parce que il ya
des étudiants qui sont boursiers
d'autres qui ont besoin effectivement
d'un soutien qu'elle ya un job étudiant
certains qui sont soutenus par leurs
parents donc vous commencent à affecter
la qualité de vos études parce que vous
êtes quand même là parce que vous êtes
étudiante et aux suppressions de la
réussite académique qui pèsent en plus
de tout le reste sur vous moi ça va
affecter mes études à partir du moment
où on est passé au tout distant ciel
parce que le tout distant ciel ça veut
dire être potentiellement sur son ordi
à tort sur une plage horaire entre mythe
et 20h30 avec du coup finalement même
pas la pause qu'on peut avoir en temps
normal qui est ne serait-ce que d'aller
d'un amphithéâtre à un autre pour
certains de pouvoir fumer une cigarette
ou un prendre un café enfin décompresser
cinq minutes finalement et visiblement
prendre un café semble être un problème
mais mais ça a affecté puisque on avait
plus l'impression d'être vraiment en
train de suivre un cours on avait
l'impression d'être comme si on était
sûr sur youtube en fait en train de
regarder une vidéo qui aurait envie de
suivre une vidéo qui dure trois heures
puis d'enchaîner avec une autre puis
encore une autre
vient ensuite une fois que l'ordinateur
est éteint ah bah non en fait il faut le
rallumer parce qu'il ya les devoirs à
rendre et qu' il faut faire des
recherches internet internet il faut
avoir un bon accès en plus pour enfin ça
ont enchaîné en fait des situations donc
bien sûr qu'ils étaient déjà présentes
mais c'est une accentuer les inégalités
c'est comme gary vous le voir en vrai
qu'à la télé
oui sur sur les étudiants
en fait on ça fait ça fait de longues
semaines pour ne pas dire de longs mois
qu'on que que le gouvernement en tout
cas n'a pas voulu entendre et
aujourd'hui c'est en train d'exploser à
la tête de tout le monde et on en train
de se rendre compte ce qui se passe sur
la précarité
il ya déjà des étudiants qui vivent dans
une extrême précarité des étudiants qui
vivaient d'un petit boulot souvent dans
la restauration pour survivre et qui
aujourd'hui la safer mieux avoir ce
petit malheureusement aujourd'hui qu'est
ce qu'on leur apporte en solutions alors
des mesures et oui j'entends les repas
dans les dents dans les restos u etc
mais on voit bien c'est pas suffisant
sur les conditions d'étude mois jean jé
où on a on reçoit tous des témoignages
de français c'est la force de balance
compost j'ai reçu des témoignages
d'étudiants il ya quelques semaines
d'étudiants parisiens qui ont passé leur
présentent leurs partiels en présentiel
avec des cas contacts et des cas
positifs dans la pièce avec des
étudiants qui bat pour le besoin de
passer leurs examens n'ont pas voulu
déclarer qu'ils étaient positifs ou qu'à
contacter je trouve ça mais aberrant et
je voulais poser la question à maylis je
me permets touch pets tu passes tes
études se passe bien tout est partiel
est-ce que tu le passes en présentiel ou
en distance yale c'est important que ça
vous dépasse en présentiel
pour rebondir sur ce que tu peux y aller
ce que tu as dit on a reçu effectivement
des des messages aussi d'étudiants qui
avaient passé leurs examens dans de
mêmes conditions et d'autres qui avait
même publié les réponses de leur
administration lié au fait qu'ils
étaient malades qui ne pouvaient pas du
coup se rendre aux examens et du coup va
finalement qu'est ce qu'on fait pour eux
et la plupart des réponses a été bien
vous venez en votre page sauf que pour
certains dans le cas justement je peux
pas tout centré autour des 3e année
puisque pareil les primo entrants
c'est aussi extrêmement déboussolant
pour eux de se retrouver après ne pas
avoir passé le bac dans cette
situation-là d'accueil à l'université
mais pour nous pour les 3e année rendre
un dossier un master à une autre
université
finalement le dossier est vide en disant
non je n'ai rien fait moi mais
rattrapage seront pour certains dans
quelques semaines et pour d'autres à la
fin de l'année universitaire c'est pas
possible
marie dit quand vous avez entendu parler
de ce parfois la détresse prend des
formes extrêmes les deux tentatives de
suicide
encore un étudiant qui est entre la vie
et la mort est ce que ça vous a surprise
ou en fait autour de vous il ya une
détresse tels que ça ne vous étonne même
plus déjà rassurés nous ça vous a jamais
traversé l'esprit car est ce qu'on peut
dire aujourd'hui que ça n'a jamais
traversé l'esprit de personne ne dirait
dit finalement si demain je me connecte
pas il se passe quoi honnêtement je
pense que beaucoup d'étudiants et on
pensait après il ya une différence entre
le penser en se disant ça ferait quoi et
avant la volonté et le ruminer pendant à
repenser comment d'avoir inventé l'idée
du suicide pour ne pas avoir la
commettre en fait ce qui amène à la gare
tuer l'idée sur moi qui ce soir est
possible l'idée du suicide c'est quand
on peut plus comme je disais avant se
projeter alors on a le passé ou
inconsciemment on ne voit que les côtés
négatifs de ce qu'on a eue avant et on
peut pas se projeter puisque c'est très
angoissant les périodes convient
actuelle donc un arrêt sur images on est
coincé en train de passer qui a été
parfois difficile et qu'il faut quand
même
[Musique]
accepter et un futur qui est pleine
d'incertitudes et de et de circonstances
actuelles plus qu'en que ce gène est à
présent elles se font donc et un arrêt
sur image alors qu'on voudrait se
projeter surtout pour les jeunes comme
vous donc et on est coincé entre une
situation il n'y a pas de solution
viendra devant le docteur ils ont la vie
devant l'as tu peux te dire un moment
donné aa je sais pas quel âge tu as
vingt ans vingt jours allez je vais
perdre six mois je vais perdre
maintenant
mais qu'est ce que c'est dans une vie
mais avoir des idées effectivement
suicidaire je trouve que c'est
dramatique c'est un lyonnais cela robben
l'avenir de nos normes et autour de vos
est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens vous
sentez un peu la limite en train de
glisser vers quelque chose de grave qui
pourrait prendre des formes que comme
celle que j'ai cités a bien sûr avec les
témoignages qu'on a réussi on s'est
rendu compte que même au niveau de jeu
ne la petite promotion ça me prenait des
proportions qui était plus importante
que ce qu'on pouvait imaginer jeu comme
je vous ai dit on culpabilise en fait
d'être mal et donc on n'ose même plus en
parler a finalement puisque quand quand
on en parle on dit oh mais ça va passer
si rien vous continuer d'avoir des cours
on nous met ce poids là où mais bien sûr
quand je vois que ça on arrive à des
tentatives de suicide ou des suicides
puisque il y en a eu aussi 20 heures il
y en a eu à lyon il y en a eu à
montpellier j'ai pas fait non plus toute
la presse pour savoir exactement la
liste et je veux dire depuis le premier
confinement on en voit trop souvent en
fait parce que un c'est déjà un de trop
finalement ça devrait pas arriver qu'à
notre âge comme vous dites on n'est plus
le perspectives d'avenir et qu'on se
dise pas finalement c'est fini